Can any of the toxicity labs, if we want to retest, be covered by insurance?
No.
So, none of the like the mosaic or toxicity labs or parasite labs or any of the functional medicine labs are never going to be covered by insurance.
So, but I have really good insurance.
I have Medicare plus blah blah blah.
It's still not going to be covered.
It's not going to be covered.
Now, if you have like Samaritan's ministries, which technically isn't a insurance, we've had people get that cover.
It covered under that, but that's pretty much the only one.
So, and that is you still have to pay for it and then you submit it and hope they cover it.
So, that's not a for sure thing, but insurance is not going to cover any of the other functional labs.
Now, insurance may cover a CBC with the forageal and a couple heads of metabolic panel and a tumor marker panel.
If it's ordered by your primary practitioner.
But many times you go into the primary practitioner and you say, this is what I want.
And they order something completely different.
But it's worth a shot.
I mean, if you can get your Medicare to cover some of those labs, and that's just money in your pocket.
You paid for it in the first place.
I think you should try to do that.
It also presupposes that you have a medical doctor that you have a relationship with.
So, I always try to get people, encourage people to seek that out if they can so that they can get.
So, we can get regular labs.
It would be the functional medicine labs, but regular labs covered and done on a regular basis.
I just think the more frequently that we could do those labs, the more objective data that we have to formulate a working...
and diagnose the criteria of how to move forward and where you're at and how we're progressing.
So, the more data we have, the better.